we are so excited we all are so excited
she has been my human encouragement
um and um she's here ladies and
gentlemen founder of the Magnolia Empire
and her book the stories we tell I I
drink up everything she says here we go
Joanna Gaines everybody
this is
[Applause]
it works for many occasions yes I've
worn this many times right it's a good
staple easy I want to ask you so much
about your house but we can talk about
that later I know it's still in the
world there right now okay so back story
is I send
um Joanna and I've even reached out to
you and chip on social when I'm like
demo day and then I'll cut to myself
three months later screaming and crying
I know that feeling yes text me kindly
and say just keep going keep moving
forward and then I'll send you another
picture of like some progress and I'll
even hear like what's that tile that I'm
like the details though you're so good
well I I okay so I want to take you
through and get your thoughts on a few
things so
so the context that maybe you should
know going into this is I would watch
you on fixer-upper
I don't know six seven years ago and I
was going through such a major life
change I was separating I was taking my
family from California to New York I
knew that I I had struggled doing movies
while I had kids because I didn't want
to pretend to be other people I wanted
to be their mom like I just I I needed a
big life change but I didn't know where
I was going and I felt so lost and
um I would watch you and you gave me the
courage to believe that I could take my
life in a New Direction because I love
design and I love homemaking and I
realized this is what I wanted to pour
myself into I had other interests I
wanted to do news and design and food
and human interest and you know speak to
people like a lot of my journey has been
engaging with people so could I find a
path to that and you're the one who made
me believe I could
[Applause]
thank you
good to see now and all the stuff that
you're doing the joy that you're
infusing in all these different places
the conversations you're having I mean
you the second we stepped into this
building you could feel the joy of just
the people around you you your spirit
like you you've landed in a really
beautiful place
[Applause]
I never thought I would hear coming from
the person what do you advise people if
they come up to you and say like I'm
ready to be a more realized version of
myself I'm ready to Pivot I'm ready to
try new things maybe they're things that
have always been in me but they're not
what I'm known for right I think there's
just a certain trajectory that we're all
used to just in culture it's like you go
to school you get your your degree you
find the job you climb that ladder then
to retirement I just feel like we're it
just needs to be shaken up a little bit
where the pivot is really the PowerPoint
in our lives where hey I've been doing
this for a while maybe I even went to
school the the craziest thing for me is
I worked in this building in New York
this is the business this is my office
I feel like when I found out this
morning this is the location because you
told the whole circle moment I write
about it in the book about being in New
York this was where I worked and I'm
here with you 20 like what a dream I
mean I would have never so my point is I
came here for one thing studied for it
five years and then journalism
journalism and then that instinct in me
to Pivot and I'm so thankful that I went
with that instinct to then start with
retail and then into design but even now
moving into food like I just feel like
as humans if we can stay curious and be
Learners like there's never a point
where you've made it you know it's just
keep learning keep your eyes open and
don't stay on the the track just to stay
on the track so and you can really read
about can't believe it's this building
this is the most full circle moment of
my life and that's why this book is so
important because you are not only
telling your story the way you write
this book is by and it and you should
savor it because it you provoke the
reader to ask themselves questions along
the way and to make their story as
relevant to the process as reading yours
which is very giving thanks for saying
that I was really I didn't want it to
feel like a memoir like when you put it
down oh I know more about Joe My Hope
was that it really it made people think
about their own life whether they could
relate to some of the things in there
some of the themes in my life that keep
popping up that or that something would
just come up as they were reading I was
hoping that when people are finished
with this that they then say I'm going
to get a pen I'm going to get a journal
I'm going to write down the story of my
life to see how everything beautiful
everything hard everything painful has
connected it's like this thread to get
me to where I am right now oh no it all
own it every piece yes take it with you
[Music]